If you had to choose right now,
how long would you want to live?
80 years.
9,120 longer.
And do you think you'll change your mind once you reach that age?
50,000 years ago,
most humans died very young.
As we learned how to use the resources around us to treat ourselves,
this got better and better.
Today,
humans are living longer and healthier lives than ever before,
but this has an unforeseen consequence.
We spend an ever increasing part of our lives being sick and in need of care.
Most of us will die in a hospital bed,
which is depressing enough by itself,
but we also have to witness the same happening to our loved ones,
except maybe we can stop this forever.
The most effective way to treat a disease is to prevent it.
It saves many more lives.
If you stop a million people from smoking than coming up with better
chemotherapies.
So one,
I'll put a halt to the cause of all disease.
The process of aging.
In a nutshell,
aging is caused by physics and not biology.
Think of cars.
Arts were down from rubbing and grinding.
Metal rusts,
filters get plowed.
The rubber cracks our bodies a worn down by trillions of tiny physical
processes,
oxygen,
radiation from the sun.
Our metabolism,
our bodies have many mechanisms to repair this damage,
but over time they become less effective.
So loud bones and muscles.
We can ask any wrinkles.
Our immune system gets weaker,
we lose our memory and our senses diminish.
There's no such thing as dying of old age.
We'll die because one of our important parts breaks.
The older we gas,
the more damaged and fragile we become until one or multiple diseases takeover
and killers unnoticed by most of us.
Longevity research has made some unprecedented advances in the last few years.
For the first time,
we're starting to understand the mechanisms behind aging and how to manipulate
them.
Aging is neither mystical nor inevitable,
and we might be able to stop or delayed during your lifetime.
We'll discuss the science behind it and how scientists are trying to stop this
in another video,
but first,
if we could,
should we end aging?
Is this a good idea?
The end of aging or life extension makes many people uncomfortable.
We're born a young,
become older and there'll be dying.
This has been the natural order for literally all of human history and getting
old is a good thing,
right?
We celebrate the idea of living long enough to experience old age.
We even called them the golden years,
but the reality is that everybody wants to become old,
but nobody wants to be old.
Think of the Greek myth of to thoroughness.
For example,
two furnace,
the lover of the Goddess Eos,
and probably an amazing dude because she begged Zeus to grant him immortality so
they could spend eternity together,
but she forgot to specifically ask for eternal youth to Furniss was granted
eternal life,
but he kept eating unable to die.
After a few hundred years,
he was reduced to the size of a grape babbling on senselessly forever.
Thousands of years ago.
Humans already fares neverending old age,
but ending aging does not mean getting weaker and weaker.
If you become too old,
it's too late and 90 year old who stopped teaching would die anyway.
After a few years,
too much damage has been done to his internal machinery.
There are already too many surfaces for disease to attack.
Instead,
the concept of life extension promises to Ann's diseases and with them the end
of a fixed maximum age.
We don't know how much we could prolong our lives.
We might make every human healthy to the currently accepted maximum age of
around 120 all.
We might stop biological aging and disease indefinitely.
Nobody knows that this point,
what's possible.
Okay,
but even if we could achieve that,
should we?
Well,
life extension is ready.
Just another phrase for medicine or the doctors are doing is trying to prolong
life and to minimize suffering.
The vast majority of health care resources are spent on the consequences of
aging.
Nearly half of your lifetime healthcare costs will be spent during your senior
years and another third during middle age.
We are actually already trying to prolong life with our current medicine.
We're just doing it very inefficiently.
Trying to stop aging from happening is not less natural than transplanting a
heart treating cancer with chemotherapy,
using antibiotics or vaccines.
Nothing humans do nowadays is purely natural anymore and we enjoy the highest
standard of living ever.
As a consequence of that,
what we're doing right now is waiting until it's too late and the machine is
failing and then we use the vast majority of our resources trying to fix it as
well as we can.
One,
it breaks down even further,
but life extension still feels hubristic.
Most people assume that they will want to die once they reach a certain age,
and this might still be true.
The idea of avoiding death and Tylee is off putting for many,
the end of biological aging would not mean the end of death in any way.
It's more like a summer evening when you were a kid and your mom calls you
inside.
You just wanted to keep playing,
have a little more fun during sunset before you went to sleep.
It's not about playing outside forever,
just a little longer until we feel tired.
If you imagine a world without disease where you and your loved ones could live
in good health for another 100 or 200 years,
how would this change us?
Would we take better care of our planet?
If we knew we would be around longer?
If we could work for 150 years,
how much time would we spend figuring out what we're good at?
How much more time would we spend learning would the intense feeling of pressure
and stress?
Many of us are feeling right now,
go away or get worse.
So asking again,
if you could choose how long to live right now in good health and with your
friends and family,
what's your personal answer?
What would you like your future to look like?
But maybe you are still unconvinced.
Some nagging feeling remains that is the reaper whispering into your brain.
Watch my video to hear what he says and why you shouldn't listen.
Your eternal future may depend on it.
Go Watch the other part over at CGB grace channel.
And if you're not already subscribed,
subscribe.